I've done everything here from fix the
espresso machines to to plunge the
toilets to speak on that because I talk
about this at bner media the reason I'm
always calm is I know if every if David
starts a coup and takes every employee
with him I have no fear because I know
how to do every job yes I think a lot of
entrepreneurs make that mistake Vayner
Nation I'm extremely excited I'm
actually excited because visually this
will be an interesting episode as well
so go check YouTube if you want to watch
this one because we're in this
incredible setting here in Midtown
Manhattan with a fellow entrepreneur
from the East Coast I admire very much
Gregory's coffee I actually tell the
story pretty often when I talk about
Vayner media like how we moved offices
and Gregory's coffee is actually in that
story because when we moved to 23rd 24th
in park literally every day it was kind
of like when we started to somewhat grow
up into like the alpha not just complete
scrap in the mud Ridiculousness of the
first couple years every day there would
be aund Gregory coffe cups because
everybody go downstairs multiple times a
day and so we are here to talk to
Gregory from Gregory's coffee really
talk about entrepreneurship his journey
I want you to know about him because I
think a lot of you actually should be
going on a similar path and we're also
here to talk about the incredible V
friends Gregory coffey's collaboration
Gregory and I just did uh Good Day New
York but we're really excited about the
Jolly Jacko pumpkin spice chai latte
collab that we're doing that's running
here in October so if you're visiting
New York City get to A Gregory's find a
jolly Jacko beverage pick up a
collectible sticker flip it on eBay or
whatever else and so I've just been
really fun we're about a weekend seeing
all the tweets and the pictures of
people having this cup in their hand the
QR code we'll get into all of that and
more but first let me say hello to
Gregory how are you my friend I'm doing
well how are you I'm good let tell the
vayer nation a little bit about yourself
literally comic book number one take the
floor for two three minutes four minutes
where you grew up what kind of kid were
you just give us the zero to day one of
opening your first Gregor's kind of
story let's ground you for the audience
son of an immigrant you know my father
came here uh from Greece at a young age
my both my parents are from Brooklyn
that's where I started my journey sort
of grew up in this sort of New York
entrepreneurial household so my father
was a Serial entrepreneur left College
to to pursue his dream which was running
his own business so he was working at a
doughnut shop at the time when the
opportunity was there to take over that
he decided to leave school take over
that doughnut shop and that was the
first of his many foray into the food
and beverage World here in New York city
so um where was that donut shop that was
all the way down in like Benson Hurst
area I believe it's still there but it's
probably changed names quite a few times
since then but he went on from Donuts to
the classic New York City Deli you
probably saw all over the city in the
90s they s sold everything when I was
probably in my teens he he had launched
this panini press sandwich concept which
there was about seven of them at their
Peak so I sort of grew up watching my
father um grind grind every day you know
I probably didn't get to see him as much
as I would have liked but he was that
was the the deal back then plus like not
as convenient now with phones and
connectivity so definitely loved my
Summers going to work with him tell
stories of when I was seven he used to
have me down in lower Manhattan doing
deliveries for him in the summer uh so
he had a store down by Wall Street he'd
send me to send bacon egg and cheese and
coffee across the street and I'd show up
with my Yankee hat little kid and these
people would be surprised to see their
delivery boy probably being uh in second
grade uh I have a son who's now eight
and I could never imagine him letting
him loose in lower Manhattan but my
father thought it was a good idea you
gots I I
mean at the time I probably got two
bucks and I thought I was the richest
guy in the world but uh at the time I
didn't realize what was happening but my
father was sort of giving me a lot of
the tools that would later help me in
life which was you know showing about
hard work dedication all the experience
in FNB so I mean my whole life is not
necessarily about FNB but it has really
been the fabric were you were you a good
student or were I was so so you were
getting good GR grades for dad's stuff
my dad also immigrant family good grades
were that was it was like you know if I
got a 97 it wasn't great it's like
what'd you get wrong you know I got very
fortunate I got very bad grades and I
was born in the Soviet Union so I'm like
first gen but my and my mom would ground
me but there wasn't that which is so
common in immigrant Families my mom
didn't play that game she had a
different point of view that I had it
and she wanted me to be accountable to
bad grades but it's really been
interesting as I got older I didn't
realize that I was in an incredibly
small minority of immigrant families
where the mom and my dad worked like
sounds like the way your dad did and my
dad wouldn't have known if I got A's FS
or Z's or W's like had no clue but my
mom she grounded me for every bad report
card which was four times a year though
the summer one she was lenient a couple
days and I'd go out and play so the the
pressure to get good RADS was there yes
and did school come easy to you or did
you have to really work at it to get
those 97s it's it's odd to say but it
did come easy to me no I ask it that way
because there are just a lot of people
who are naturally good at school they
understand the system they understand
what they need to do I I was able to
achieve you know good grades I was a you
know top of my class even in college in
the honors program at Boston University
undergraduate business school um
ironically I was about to reference my
brother AJ who barely worked in got
great grades and he went to be as well
oh really so maybe there's a trend there
but I did enjoy my time at be but also
the one time that caught up with me was
law school where I was able to manage
time and you know get the grades I
always expected but then I get to law
school and the workload was so much more
I couldn't just approach it the same way
I had done previously so when I went to
got to law school that first semester
when I was getting towards finals I was
realizing it was a little different um I
still W up doing well but it was just
for me it was it was a transition as to
how to approach it and that was probably
the most pivotal time for me learning
that I couldn't just rely on natural
ability that or you know ability to kind
of recall things think through things
law school taught me you have to work
really really hard if you want to
achieve what you really expect to also
taught me about writing and a lot of
things that also for whatever reason in
business and all these things wasn't
business school wasn't as critical so
did you go to law school thinking you
were going to practice law I did you did
yeah oh interesting goad so again I I
went to school not thinking I was going
to work in the the food and beverage
industry wasn't necessarily cool back
then uh it wasn't I you know you'd go to
work for my dad I'd come home smelling
like grease with ripped jeans but not
because it was cool because they got
caught on a nail at work you know and it
was like you know not glamorous you know
I admired my father but it wasn't
something that I you felt there was
almost like most immigrant families when
Dad or Mom is working in that
environment there's almost this
subconscious if not outwardly conscious
conversation of like well you're going
to use this as a stepping stone and
you're going to do this more bougie
thing oh my mother cried when I told her
I wasn't going to be a lawyer um my
grandmother years after I I completed
law school and I was working at Gregor
used to call me her grandson the lawyer
because they were that mentality of
office job professional uh whereas the
stigma about being an entrepreneur but
an entrepreneur in the food business did
not have the same sort of cache I tell a
lot of kids now you can't imagine what
being a chef means today compared to 25
years ago being a chef 25 years ago was
the help exactly
now there's celebrity chefs and you know
the culinary explosion in our society
and that's wonderful thank God but like
to your point I'm very aware of you know
it seems crazy how long ago was this
when you start Gregor's 17 years yeah I
mean like it's just actually profound to
think about entrepreneurship and food
and beverage entrepreneurs rebranding in
our society today as like completely the
other side of the pillow I think it
started with fast casual yeah I think
that's just literally the the nomen
you're getting away from fast food where
you could start saying things that
people used to associate with just Quick
Service you know grabbing a salad
grabbing a a coffee to now it's an
elevated experience and they started
designated it as fast casual or fine
casual whatever it was but getting away
from oh it's just like another you know
Deli you know McDonald's esque type
business so you're in law school yeah I
assume there's the great entrepreneurial
story like what's the moment that you're
like [__] this I'm doing Gregor's I was
working my first law job first summer
after school they offered me a position
and I kept saying to myself I can do
this job it was this then kind of
reverted to how things were in the past
they would give me a mountain of work in
their eyes I would complete it in two
hours and then I would go back and be
like what else do I have to do I just it
felt very easy to me what the tasks they
were giving me to complete so I felt
like I could do that job I could make
money doing it I really had no passion
for it the more I was in it I was like
this just feels like work and it wasn't
something I enjoyed to do I kept saying
you know my whole life seeing my father
run his own businesses I guess there was
this thing in the back of my mind that
maybe one day I would open my own
business I didn't know what it was so I
stopped and said you know I've got all
this experience I've been doing this
thing my whole life but I've always been
working at my father's locations
thinking I'm helping my dad not could
this be something I actually want to do
as a career so it was the moment of
talking to my father saying like you
know I don't think I want to practice
law he had one of his locations it was a
sandwich shop literally across the
street from my law school so I was a
customer my first year he needed help he
needed a manager said would you let me
run the store he thought it was a little
odd request um but first he's like if
this is what you really want to do sure
so my grades did suffer second year when
I did that but the business picked up
quite a bit under my you know leadership
tutelage I realized I was good at it
mainly because I've been doing it my
whole life sort of that Malcolm Gladwell
10,000 hours I realized I literally from
shaving carrots when I was five making
deliveries when I was seven watching all
things my dad did it's so crazy we were
literally just downstairs getting some
coffees while the team here was prepping
upstairs I can't go into an
establishment like this and not pay
attention to POs to how fast is the
register moving think about the thing
you know the most and think about how
you look at it versus people that know
nothing about it for I'll give you an
example somewhere in my mid 20s late 20s
I was like wait a minute look at all
these people at this restaurant the way
they're drinking wine they're drinking
like water they're not even thinking I
would take like an 8 minute like thought
process of like smelling it tasting it
it was like consumed me or like when I
watch the Jets and like I watch casual
like you just when you know something so
much better than the rest so for me
retail and restaurants and things of
that nature I don't walk in and order a
coffee I walk in and order a Gregory's
coffee a jolly Jacko pumpkin spice uh
chai latte I also though I'm watching
the staff trying to figure out why the
POS is doing what it's doing thinking
about how clean the store is which is an
incredible challenge in New York City
was hard enough in New Jersey in the
suburbs traffic like watching how people
were walking by the street I'm curious
if they would like look at the
storefront noticed like 30 of them
looking at their phone was like oh right
like storefront real estate is kind of
like outdoor media like 50 years ago
this like the signage in your store
converted better than it does now cuz
people are looking at the phone just all
these random things that like literally
ran through my mind in two seconds step
first yeah I mean it's it honestly as
we've expanded sometimes it can be a
problem because if I haven't been to a
store for a long time sometimes I may
have this anxiety as to what am I going
to see because I know I have these
sensors that start firing the minute I
walk in it's like that's not correct my
father has my father has one store every
day he's really just unhappy on his
drive to work which is 45 minutes cuz
basically he knows he's going to walk in
and see something he doesn't like and
he's got one store and he's there every
day so for you having dozens there's an
appreciation effect cuz my team knows
that like I'm I will lift them up
there's things that they're working hard
um some of them are newer at this some
of them are doing it for a while but
even that you can get blinders if you go
to the same spot every single day so
when I come in and I give it I give
feedback or Point things out that maybe
they were missing it's all with the
mindset of just yeah like we're I'm I'm
not here trying to catch them do
something wrong delivery this goes back
to cander like I think about kind cander
versus not kind cander everyone
listening knows owner manager who's got
a bunch of stores we've all seen the
cliche we all are thinking what I'm
about to say which is that boss that
walks in when she or he's going to look
at all 10 stores and just starts yelling
and and leads by fear yeah and I think I
don't think I've ever yelled in the 17
years how about your dad was he a little
more old school no that wasn't his
disposition either he worked as hard or
harder than anybody there and he has
people who've been working with him for
40 years they've literally the people
that have stayed with him
in a food and beverage establishment
which is probably the most rare and I
always took that which was Tre people
with respect let's let's let's bring
some value to everybody who's listening
and managing let's stay on this for a
second what do you think in the 17 years
that you've been running this actually
let's context it for everybody Gregory's
coffee how many locations which which
states 36 about to open number 37 where
in Daran Connecticut um actually we're
having our final inspections right now
so I do have a little bit in the back of
my mind hopefully it's going okay up
there oh trust me I'm thinking about
nine other things while we're doing this
go ahead but we're in New York uh New
Jersey Connecticut and Washington DC uh
so 36 today hopefully 37 by the end of
the week any plans for any extra States
as you little little Rhode Island little
Boston a little this this this northeast
Mid-Atlantic Corridor certainly is in
right in my wheelhouse my in-laws are up
in Rhode Island so they talk ask me all
the time we definitely love to get down
into that Virginia market so yeah kind
of bridging this northeast 95 in the 17
years from location one which was what
2006 24th in park first one okay ours
yes no no isn't that what's so funny
notice what I just said that was so
weird ours that's amazing okay from that
store to the one you're about to open in
Connecticut what do you think from day
one because you like me had a lot of
training as a kid from day one was your
biggest strength that you continue to be
great at where you've doubled down or
refined and what do you think was your
biggest weakness in hindsight that
you've been able to close the gap on and
even above and beyond that if you want
to talk about that one or something else
what is the thing that can that you're
still potentially struggling with as a
manager of such a conglomerate so I
think my biggest strength from all along
was just my passion my dedication my
unwillingness to let things go arai so
I'm just you willed it yes I've W
certain things into existence by sheer
effort by intestinal fortitude yeah I
would you know my team would probably
tell you I'm you know the Larry Bird I'm
the first guy I'm I am in our stores
with somebody who works for Vayner media
at our gr location every every morning
they open the door they open the doors
I'm there minutes before after they open
so 6:00 in the morning and then I'm here
you know 600 7 8:00 at night whatever it
is I'm usually the one turning off the
lights and that's and then weekends too
if anybody needs me I'm always available
my wife might might have a few things to
say about my unfettered availability
my team feels it and they appreciate it
so I think there's a lot of things that
I've just been unwilling to let fail um
and my team feels that I think it kind
of Might tie into my biggest weakness
which is sometimes my inability to let
others do do their thing give them the
room what is the balance of
micromanaging or coming in and being the
leader that's the balance you've been
struggling with at times right yeah I
mean and I think a lot of it is um we
were small for a long long time I mean
we had 18 locations and there was
probably three total corporate employees
including myself it's only recently
where we've even started to expand in a
corporate team and where I've started to
have others who are capable of taking on
responsibilities but I think people need
to hear this who judge like work ethic
or judge what you're talking about now I
think everybody who's listening and hit
me up on Twitter Gary be if you agree
with this if you own a business it is
like a dog it's like a child it's your
baby you know obviously that resonates
with me I don't view you as like this
crazy guy what I view that is I get it
this is like part of your family when
people don't have a business and aren't
entrepreneurs I'm incredibly empathetic
that they don't understand in the same
way I'll make the one that I do think
people understand for all the people
right now who have a dog who judge or
laugh at their friends who don't
understand cuz they don't have a dog
what it feels like to be a dog owner and
what it feels like and why you cry when
the dog passes away or is sick it's a f
family member Believe It or Not That is
what a business is to a true bread
entrepreneur I mean it's it's it's
certainly people refer to me as Greg
from gregories I am this business is an
extension of me as AO exactly it's hard
to get away from it you know impressed
with that I'm like actually thinking
about rebranding Vayner media I think
Gary B needs to take over for the very
very very very lucky black hat I like I
look at the logo here and I'm like you
know what I think he figured it out so I
think you kind of hit it a little bit
there but that uh the the allowing or
the you know giving others some of the
things that again I have another gift in
a curses I've done everything here from
fix the espresso machines to plge the
toilets to speak on that because I talk
about this at bner media the reason I'm
always calm is I know if every if David
our friend Roser starts a coup and takes
every employee with him I have no fear
because I know how to do every job yes I
think a lot of entrepreneurs make that
mistake for sure even my father would
tell me when we started roasting our own
coffee he's like don't forget you need
to know how to do that too in the event
something ever happen because that's his
old immigrant mentality too that's right
you're the last line of defense whatever
happens I mean there's been times where
like I had to drive the truck right like
the delivery we couldn't deliver it's
like well am I going to open tomorrow
there I remember a major snowstorm
probably like 2011 12 where the city got
shut down my store in 44th and 6th it's
all hotels on that block nobody could
leave everything was shut down my store
we were baking everything out of our
store uh 24th in park at the time in the
basement there were people that all the
hotels couldn't get any food so we baked
the the product at 24th in park I put on
like snowsuit carried it like to a
Subway got there carried it through more
snow and people were like grabbing food
out of my my hands out of the baskets
cuz they literally had nothing to eat on
that block and I'm like I'm walking in
you know carrying as much product as I
could and my team was like surprised
right that I would do this but I'm like
who else is going to do this cuz I I
literally it's hard for me to sit and
watch something not happen if I have the
ability to make it fixed I told a story
for a long time my most famous Wine
Library story is a woman in Bergen
County getting a delivery to the wrong
place of Beringer white zendel which is
$3 a bottle a $36 case of wine
misdelivered she calls and complains
it's in December with bad weather it's
one of the busiest days in the store I
am the disproportionate leading
salesperson in the store like every
third customer that was going to spend
$2 $3,000 on collectible wine came in
and says where's Gary is Gary here
where's Gary and I knew that I had a
moment where I did it for two reasons
one this lady the I'm sorry the her son
called and was really complaining
because she was really upset because she
needed her baringer white zadel for the
holidays she was elderly in her 90s and
I knew that it was an opportunity for me
to show that customer over everything no
matter what kind of customer and I took
a case of Beringer from the warehouse
downstairs threw it in my car drove to
Bergen County delivered a tour and came
back missed an hour and a half lost tens
of thousands of dollars in Revenue
potential during that time but it became
a story that became connective tissue
for my company to speak about like
exactly what you're saying if you as a
leader are able to fix I think too many
leaders would rather blame their team
for not working than jumping in and
getting dirty and fixing it oh yeah I
mean there's a book that my priest had
recommended me at one point and then
kind of really struck a tone with me
called Extreme ownership I don't know if
you've heard of it I can't read for [__]
which is why I H the great I mean at the
end of the day the concept that it says
is that if if something is within your
control like within your four walls or
your your sphere of influence and you
can't H and if something doesn't go
right and you can't honestly say I did
everything in my power to make this have
worked well then you should look at
yourself and say it's on me it's not on
them so you know i' sort of taken that
to heart where I don't like plasting
blame I'm I'm right in the trenches with
everybody else so if I especially when
you're the owner founder like you are
like you hired those people right like
when I look at my incredible team that
I'm looking at right now like these six
people like I hired them and if I you
know CU even if it's indirectly Sid who
runs the team if he's hired one of the
individuals here well I hired him to
hire them I will never understand this
Obsession of blame when you have full
control
what's the easy route right I could
always just point the finger and say
well a societal issue I mean I believe
that so much of our unhappiness right
now is predicated that you want to blame
the mayor of New York you want to blame
the president you want to blame a a
party you want to blame social media you
want to BL I had a friend who's blame
spent the entire 30 minutes blaming
social media and the mainstream media
and I'm like what about you like like
what what are you consuming I mean we
experienced this mid to late kind of
coid where there was a I was doing the
thing where I was blaming coid on issues
we were experiencing well oh well this
door might be slow because of Co or
that's happening because of Co and then
I felt like what am I doing I'm saying
like you for you there's people in the
street if they're not coming in they're
going somewhere else they're going
somewhere else and it must be something
we're doing or not doing so it caused us
to kind of look we made adjustments
tweaked and what was the biggest tweak
you made in that scario I mean our our
food our our food program our customer
service just how we even how we packed
bags to like how we made it easy for
people to to access things so we had to
move things around rearrange even uh
reconfigure our menu to you know there's
points where there's just less options
available so people were looking for a
one stop people used to be comfortable
bouncing to two three different places
they'll get their coffee from here
sandwich from here muffin from there now
it's like I don't have the time nor do I
have the interest in going so like how
can we update what we did to make it
more appealing to what people today are
looking for even like we're talking
about delivery right like we didn't we
weren't very good at delivery because we
didn't do very much of it we weren't
packing them very well they would show
up and product would spill just cuz it
wasn't it wasn't your core competency we
would maybe get one or two deliveries a
day pre-o now it's like dozens a day per
store so we had to get better at it you
know now those scores have gotten
significantly better let's talk about
collaborations since we have one
together with be friends and this Jolly
Jacko pumpkin spice chai latte delicious
go get one oh yeah I'm I'm pretty like
pumped with the feedback of the you know
everyone thinks their baby is the best
looking so I'm not going to judge on how
delicious this is I'm just reading
Twitter and you and the team have done a
great job clearly people like Twitter or
is it still Twitter I just call it
Twitter forever I'm old school I still
say tweets but I'm like what do you say
am I doing an X am I I'm Xing something
out I don't know I I'm really lost that
has how to describe this yeah I'm just
very comfortable calling a Twitter but
I'll change if the world wants it I'm
consumer Centric how do you think about
collaborations when was your first
collaboration if you can recall why do
collaborations how should people that
are listening right now that may have a
business that is in the kind of demo
that is possible to do collaborations
even if they have one store or one
product I think collabs are very
interesting and I I wonder how you think
about it and what's the history of
collabs so to me collaborations have to
make sense you have to have people are
working with somebody that is of like
mine where why this made so much sense
to me just for everything you stand for
aligns very closely with what we stand
for and there's a lot of times like oh
this is a great business opportunity
right this person has reach but it's
kind of like how we create a blend like
you might wine I'm sure is very similar
when you're talking about how do you
what are you looking for the end product
right so when we're talking about coffee
I want rich flavor unique flavors crisp
clean Balan sweetness it's hard
sometimes to find one single coffee that
can give me everything I want it's
almost impossible the best wines in the
world World always blend multiple grapes
almost always most people don't know
that and same with coffee I mean maybe
because we out and out call them Blends
I want this my house blend my dark roast
blend but it's like how can I find
individual components that when you put
them together give me the end result
that I'm looking for so similarly with
the collaboration it's like how can I
find Partners or people or whatever it
is that can help us become a better
version of ourselves or expand our reach
or to connect with people that or Del
like your customers right exactly
there's certain people that maybe they
love V friends they're ingesting VOR
Media or you or your content and maybe
they were aware of Gregor's maybe not
somebody somebody drove from South
Carolina to be one of your DC locations
that's great news that's cool stuff
right like you just those things add up
I mean of course and it's just like but
I'm not again it's not just about like
the business or the dollars it's like
how do you do things that make sense in
do dollars you would go for the for the
entity whether that's someone like
Taylor Swift or like a media outlet that
can just drive the most business when it
doesn't fit the consumer can smell it
I'm kind of I mean I like fashion too
I've been doing I've been in like
magazines whatever just because handsome
like you're a model or I have friends
that work in that business so they like
to tap me when they need need need
somebody to do interesting whatever from
time to time interesting modeling I
modeling so it's like I've been in like
GQ for like as like guys of New York and
how they dress and stuff like that so
it's yeah but there's been times I've
been approached by a brand to do you
know either an ambassadorship or a
campaign and if that brand is something
I would never actually wear or I just
don't like I'm like there's like the
money I'm like yeah they want to pay me
or they're going to do this it's
transactional but I'm like it just
doesn't feel right because it's also
like what was the first collab you did
at Gregor's do you remember trying to
think or at least one of the early ones
that you can remember and I mean that we
partnered with people influencers
influencers like did anything surprise
you early on when the influencer thing
was just starting to happen where you're
like holy crap I can't believe that
person drove so much or any or anything
interest to be honest there wasn't any
collab that changed us materially but I
think also we weren't do we haven't been
doing it right this is different because
there's like a a prolonged period
there's a tale there's a lot of work
that's going into it and this is
honestly a learning experience for me
too because we've done these one-offs uh
or single events and there's no tail to
it so you might see a single pop on one
day people are driving people in but
then there's not a continued effect
where I'm seeing a lasting right you
might get some new discovery somebody
might have realized there's a location
but it's micro whereas this this podcast
what we just did with Good Day New York
that kind of like the way we're doing
the content like we worked with cores
which is a a Greek facial care company
that's cool I'm Greek yeah I get it they
connected so we're like oh we want to do
something so they we did this huge
activation on one day they had samples
and product at all the stores and
giveaways and this kind of stuff and
that day we saw a lot of attention but
then the next day it was like right back
to right back right so we've learned
that the one day one off might not be
the exact or or we did with some of
these big social influencers around
events um and we definitely Drive
traffic but if you're not doing a
prolonged continuous effort what I like
about this I always think about collabs
for me for everyone who's listening I'm
like I need them to feel like that was
the best decision they made what I liked
about this was as you recall one of my
requests is like hey I really wanted to
be a new drink like just slapping my my
Jolly jacket
on exactly it doesn't feel authentic in
Reverse what I was excited about even
when we were talking the first time and
definitely now that I'm seeing the
response I'm like oh sure we may decide
to keep doing this every season but even
if we don't CU we don't want to or you
don't cuz you don't want to it's not
right you now have a formula that you
may want to use as just your and to me
like I'm like that would be worth it for
them for everyone who's listening
basically every collab I do I basically
make pretend I'm fully the other person
and what would I say yes to I'm Blown
Away the word collab collaboration
please go Google it because what I see
from a lot of you when you try to do a
collaboration is you try to win the deal
it's what about me yeah I'm like what
are you doing like go go search It Go
understand the word and that was a big
part of me want I really wanted it
because I wanted it to be unique but I
also knew in the back of my mind well if
they crush it and I know they do a good
job over there they may that just might
become a thing they sell definitely
there's things like that where we've
tested it we have a few menu items that
were seasonal or tried something out and
they just don't leave the menu cuz
they're really great and again something
like this marrying two products our our
chai and our our pumpkin spice that
people love both on their own so put
them together and yeah it's working
really well I'm pumped about that talk
to me about and you may have no answer
for this but since we are talking about
you know for everybody who's listening
what what's really developing in V
friends land is collectibility this
podcast is coming out just as ComicCon
is probably either happening or is
happening at the end of this week into
the weekend one thing that's been blew
me away with be friends is collectible
pins if every everybody right now like
in parallel to listening to this goes to
eBay and types in be friends pins
completed items sold you'll be blown
away like just wild because I didn't
grow up collecting pins though I knew
Olympic pins and Disney pins were a
thing obviously something I grew up very
much collecting trading cards the
vriends trading cards thing is going
bananas right now also go to eBay and
look that up oh son's coming on screen
here here we go nice little pin oh there
it is this is nice like this the comic
this is pretty so anyway how about for
you as a kid GRE did you collect Comics
Magic the Gathering Pokemon sports cards
sneakers anything or you were a non-
collector so I collected sports cards
and I was I mean we didn't talk about it
earlier but I definitely played every
sport out there soccer basketball um
track basball probably best at soccer I
played that my whole life I probably I
mean I probably enjoyed that the most
but maybe my most success was throwing
javelin in high schol School oddly
enough I transitioned from running uh
doing the mile to yeah launching a spear
it just seemed like really cool uh when
I was in freshman when they they said
they line everybody up like all
everybody's going to run a Sprint long
distance start throwing some stuff
jumping and see what you're good at and
they gave me they gave me a football as
like a and I I launched it like 15 yards
farther than the starting quarterback of
the he the high school team at the time
so like all right this guy you should
throw Javelin and like got into it I
love it but the the the the quarterback
wound up quitting the team because he
couldn't bear the fact that Varsity
quarterback couldn't throw it as far as
this 9-year-old 140b freshman so anyway
that was I was like hold on Gregory I'm
not letting this go you're telling me
your freshman year as a ninth grader you
threw the football further than a
starting quarterback and that forced him
to quit yeah you might need to write a
book about this so you colle sports
cards to the stay a huge Sports guy love
it definitely was bit by the sneaker bug
in college so my father immigrant could
never uh justify paying money for
sneakers so I had one pair or whatever
reasonable I was loved Jordan sneakers
growing up but I never owned a pair so
the minute I got to college I went on
eBay whatever money that might have been
allocated for food I portioned some out
to make sure I could buy a pair of
Jordan 3s and from there it was problem
for a while um and I still have a few of
those from that are still wearable uh
don't wear them as frequently but uh
started a journey of being interested in
in that and then Clos which led to you
know being connected with some of the
fashion community and stuff like that
but today I don't collect as many things
I would say but I wish I could but I
iire well let's talk about that for a
second this is something I'm very
passionate about you answered it like
most people will I wish I could but I
think you know this like I believe and I
talk about this in marketing underpriced
attention for me it's more exciting to
find some sort of ad on Pinterest
interest right now that nobody sees than
buying a Super Bowl ad and that's how I
think about collecting of course people
collect different ways and different
budgets but let's talk about art
especially Contemporary Art right now
there are three contemporary artists in
Manhattan who she and he are making art
nobody gives a [__] it is super
inexpensive hundreds of dollars maybe a
thousand or so and literally they are
destined to be wildly collected heavily
collected
over the next two or three decades and I
think for anybody with sports cards nfts
pins comic books like there's always a
moment in every genre sneakers right now
that people are not like you think you
know what's going to be collected but
you don't always know and so I encourage
you to consider that it's not I'll H you
for the right places to look for sure to
find some of these things cuz I've done
it too there's like you know Raph
Simmons is a designer and there's some
of his pieces are extremely collectible
and I purchased a sweater on gry
alts.com at one point um I paid what at
the time I thought was we too much for
it but I was like it's worth it cuz it
was a collector's piece and I literally
tripled my money on a sweater so this is
clearly your fashion love like
collecting clothes and Handbags and all
that stuff has become very very very big
like is that something that you might
start doing I do I mean I do I I but you
wear it right I wear it I mean I have
things in my closet for 10 15 20 years
that I still wear and some of them are
worth a lot of money just because of
time and things have changed or like Tom
Brown is a designer that people love I
have stuff from like 2007 or eight when
he was still very early in what he was
doing then those pieces are are
important to other people yeah super
cool what did we not touch on anything
you want to talk about the formula
anything you want to talk about the
locations anything about Gregor's or
anything else for the general
entrepreneurs and operators that are
listening yeah I mean I think when I
think about starting Gregor's even
running it today or when people ask me
like what made you want to start this or
how do you still stay passionate about
it I think it's a making sure what
you're doing you love and you you're not
again doing it just to chase dollars
because anytime you're just trying to
make money doing something it's going to
be very hard to be successful in it it's
the biggest mistake don't you agree yeah
it's the thing I put out the most about
on content because it's like if you're
passionate and you love something like I
said earlier you're going to you're
going to make sure it does well it's not
a guarantee but your much higher
likelihood of success you genuinely
puts because I might extra $50 today or
it's I know the Buss it I want to give
it what it needs you know having
something that you care about you're
passionate about truly understanding
your position and staying true to that
like you know we say our our tagline is
see coffee differently you know what
does that mean to me it's like I don't
want to do things just like everybody
else does when people come to gregories
or we call them regulars like our our
regulars um it's like what do they
appreciate it's like that old New York
sensibility that I had running my
father's places was it had to be
delicious you had to get it quick had to
Great customer service how to be hot and
the place had to be clean if you could
do all those things at the same time you
had something for me in coffee that was
very hard to find it's a lot of places
make great cup of coffee a lot of places
can move quickly not everybody can do
them both at the same time while also
delivering it with great customer
service all those things you mentioned
you look at the POS how quickly are
people moving all those things add up to
the overall experience which is again
what I think about all the time and I
walk into my stores it's like I want to
make sure I'm seeing all those pieces
adding up together to see coffee
differently like every we want to do
every single day so yeah it's the
passion the drive the care the love and
then at the end of the day when it
affords me to be able to like collab
with someone like you and you're great
team and great products uh people
driving uh long time to get some
collectible pieces and scan this and see
some Easter egg videos and whatnot it's
so fun and just see how how much things
can develop over time uh I never would
have thought 16 17 years ago I'd be
talking about gregories and you know
scanning QR codes and opening up your
hopefully as we're sitting here your
37th 37 getting improved just getting
the one going was like all I cared about
that at the time and then then it's like
well well maybe we could do more and
then it's like well maybe this can go
further and I was like well why am I
still in New York we could try this in
DC this was 2017 and then it just goes
from there where can people find more
information about Gregor's so all of our
handles are at Gregor's coffee uh G r y
s no apostrophe coffee uh um Gregor
coffee.com you can find us you guys app
it up do you have an app we do have an
app can order ahead uh order delivery do
you become a regular on that app the
minute you sign up you're regular you're
part of us part of your joining the fam
so yeah you can find us on on socials on
the web hit our app up if you're in the
city you know we have you know all of
our products we make ourselves like I
said earlier like on the drive to give
everybody context on a drive from Good
Day New York we drove together and I was
telling telling him I wanted to pay him
a compliment when we moved that vayer
media office I was eating an obnoxious
amount of soft carbs at this point in my
life which means like baked goods and I
was blown away by the presentation and
just really the softness AKA freshness
of the products and the baking program
the bakery program at Gregor's if you're
in the tri-state area or these states
that the incredible establishment is
operating I highly recommend if you're a
muffin or croissant or C really good
[__] it's like for better wor we take it
on ourselves to be as vertically
integrated as possible control the
supply chain control quality everything
we do we make ourselves so like in this
drink you have the pumpkin spice we make
from scratch with pumpkin puree real
products real ingredients the chai we
Brew ourselves I don't milk the oats I
guess maybe that's the one thing I
depend on other people to do with the
oat milk but Dustin milk soaks a lot
okay yeah so if anybody has got a great
soaked oat milk that they think could
work for me we'll work on it but
otherwise we're trying to make
everything ourselves and we're really
proud of everything you do and we're
really excited to be part proud of you
brother I really wanted people to get to
know your story I hope you were inspired
I hope you took away one to three to
four nuggets of insight affirmation I
think you could tell now makes sense to
me why Gregory from afar knew this could
be a good collaboration because he saw
what I was talking about and we were
doing I guess you could also find me I
mean at Gregory's zotus on my handles I
I should probably talk about myself
sometimes too so connected to the brand
I'm like yeah yeah Gregory's copy
Gregory's I'm just at Gregory's motus so
spell that [__] like a yeah Gregory I
he pretty straightforward but we go g r
e g o r y and then last name Zam photus
z m f o t i s so um you never thought
about calling it Zam photus like Gregory
was a better play one of my cousins took
just the Zam photus handle so yeah I let
him have it uh my father I'm Greg my
father's George he took gam photus so
I'm like you know even though I was
early on all these things I just I had
other weird and like coffee X Clothing
whatever now they're all just Gregory
Zam photos so X Twitter whatever you
call it uh Instagram Instagram do we get
some clothing content on maybe yeah
there's there's some probably a bunch of
kids stuff good for good for you thanks
for being on Bayer Nation thank you
please uh this goes through the month of
October right yes sir uh in the month of
October get your ass to New York New
Jersey Connecticut or DC find a Gregor's
and Order loudly and proudly a jolly
Jacko pumpkin spice chai latte cold or
hot let us know on Twitter uh GBE or
befriends what you thought of it take a
photo I'm sharing a bunch of those get
some followers out of this uh hope you
have a great day thanks for listening
thank you good stuff my man thank you
nice
great